what we're looking at is a printing
plate from a world war two German
operation on his operation Bernhardt in
which the German army attempted to
counterfeit British currency that tried
to destroy the British economy my name
is dr. Vince Houghton I'm the historian
curator of the International Spy Museum
here in Washington DC the spy museum
exists to educate the public about how
important intelligence work has been
throughout our history
the economy was the strength of Great
Britain's during the Second World War
but if you could strangle that if you
could destroy that foundation then you
could bring the British nation to its
knees
the idea was to flood Britain with fake
currency so that no-one could trust the
British economic system it evolved later
on to a way to launder money and to
create fake money to pay German spies so
this plate represents an extraordinary
moment in the Second World War we think
of the war as bombers and tanks and the
blitzkrieg across Europe
but really Germany was thinking in
different ways in this case is about
economic espionage but economic warfare
you can look at it and realize how
complicated this was the British had
installed multiple security features
they had serial numbers that were very
well regulated they had watermarks on
the bills not to mention the fact that
the paper use was very specific to
British currency when you touch it it
feels right it feels like money is
supposed to actually took a long time
for the Germans to figure out so this
ten pound note is indicative of how good
these guys actually were at
counterfeiting this money the beginning
of 1945 the Germans realized the war was
coming to a close and they were going to
lose the operation gathered up all the
printing plates and all the fake
currency and decided to get rid of the
evidence and threw it into a deep lake
in Austria hopefully to never be seen
again but we did find it was
extraordinary about this artifact it's
the only surviving plate from operation
Bernhard we can actually make out the
carving in the artisan ship and how much
craftsmanship went into creating this
object
[Music]
the reason I like this artifact so much
is that it really brings across the idea
that you can win wars in different ways
this is indicative of intelligence
agencies and governments trying to find
the edge the way to defeat their enemy
any way possible
[Music]
you